This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down,
这是一个iHeart播客。百分之百真人。在Look Back at It播客中。从1979年开始，这对我是个重要时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·恩格斯。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，
and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all?
并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。我们的朋友、喜剧演员同行以及最喜欢的作家。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。真是疯狂的一年。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听Look Back at It。嘿，大家最近怎么样？
You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor it? It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax.
欢迎收听由你喜爱的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖恩斯带来的《知难而进》（Learn the Hard Way）。这个空间探讨黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都绝对不安全的坦诚对话，而你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士交流。有多少男人穿着西装或盔甲？它向世界释放出信号：你可不是好惹的。但这并不意味着只要你有这种能力，就必须这样做。在iHeart广播应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听并学习知难而进。2023年，《黄金单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控生下了双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。
You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen's, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through. the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Ranjini. My mind was blown.
埃伦斯女士，这份特定的检测报告你篡改了两次，对吧？我篡改了一次检测报告。这需要一大群互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一名女同性恋者，迈克尔·兰吉尼。我惊呆了。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《爱情陷阱》播客。
2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%.
2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析我们在奇怪的现代世界中培养心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。
That's TWA percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe.
也就是iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方的“TWA percent”。当一群女性发现她们都与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将是他的最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到他应得的下场。我们总是说，相信你的好姐妹。收听《好姐妹》。相信我，宝贝。
On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. Welcome to our 2025 Valentine's Day episode. Every single year, I like to cover like a specific topic around love and dating and relationships for this special time of the year.
在iHeart广播应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方。大家好。欢迎回到节目中。欢迎回到播客。新听众，老听众，无论你身在世界的哪个角落。非常高兴你能回来收听新的一期节目，当然，我们要剖析我们20多岁时的心理。欢迎来到我们2025年情人节特辑。每一年，我都喜欢在这个特殊的时间里，探讨一个关于爱、约会和关系的特定主题。
And if you're listening to this after Valentine's Day, you know what? Let's just pretend it's Valentine's Day. Show yourself some self-love today. Show someone that you love some love today just for no reason. Every day can be Valentine's Day. I will stop with the cliches right now so we can get into the episode. But yes, thank you so much for all the love you guys have shown me over the past year. I feel like this is about to be a crazy year with my book coming out in April, obviously with Mantra also out in the world, my new podcast. So hopefully this episode teaches you how to love yourself a little bit more, but also how to have healthy relationships with others and, you know, recognize compatibility and recognize how important that is.
如果你是在情人节之后听到这期的，你知道吗？让我们假装今天就是情人节吧。今天对自己好一点。今天无缘无故地给你爱的人一些爱。每一天都可以是情人节。我马上就不说这些陈词滥调了，这样我们就可以切入正题了。不过是的，非常感谢大家过去一年对我的支持。我觉得随着我的书在四月出版，当然还有Mantra也和大家见面，也就是我的新播客，今年注定会是疯狂的一年。所以希望这一集能教你如何多爱自己一点，同时也教你如何与他人建立健康的 RELATIONSHIPS，你知道的，认识到契合度并意识到它是多么重要。
That is my segue into what we are talking about today, which is, yes, compatibility. What makes people just click? What really underlies those relationships that just work and seem so easy and calm and safe? And how can we make sure that we know compatibility when we feel it, especially in kind of a modern world that's very much about instant gratification and about passion and chemistry? How do we find that love that really loss? I want to talk about five deep signs of emotional and psychological compatibility between two people that you may not be looking for in a relationship or even in a platonic relationship.
这就是我今天要聊的内容的过渡，那就是，没错，契合度。是什么让人们一拍即合？那些运作良好、看似轻松、平静和安全的感情背后，究竟隐藏着什么？在这样一个高度追求即时满足、激情和化学反应的现代社会里，我们如何确保自己在感受到契合时能够认出来？我们如何找到真正持久的爱？我想聊聊两个人之间精神和心理契合的五个深层迹象，这些可能是你在寻找恋爱对象甚至普通朋友时没有刻意去寻找的。
what are the signs that it's meant to be or unfortunately not meant to be. The reason I really wanted to do this episode and cover this topic is because I have in the past been someone who was confused, chemistry and compatibility. Now, chemistry to me is all about attraction and emotional intensity and excitement and a magnetism that pulls you together. It's definitely more physical than emotion. and also it's quite fast. It's quite rapid compared to compatibility, which often simmers below the surface and takes a little bit longer to reveal itself. It's why you hear these stories of people who
哪些迹象表明这是命中注定，或者不幸并非命中注定。我之所以非常想做这一期节目并探讨这个主题，是因为我过去也曾是一个把化学反应和契合度搞混的人。对我来说，化学反应全关于吸引力、情感强度、兴奋感以及将你们拉到一起的磁场。它绝对比情感更偏向生理层面。而且它发生得相当快。与契合度相比，它相当迅速，而契合度通常在表面下酝酿，需要更长的时间才会显现出来。这就是为什么你会听到这样的故事：人们
are friends for years and then suddenly are like, wait, are you the one for me? I think the moment that we realize a deep compatibility with someone, it's very hard to ignore. I also believe that we can have both. do need the passion and the fire. You know, you do need to really feel like you are obsessed with them and that you love them. But if weeks and months go by and down the road, you realize you can't communicate, you don't actually understand each other. It's not as effortless as you think. It can be a really rude awakening.
做朋友多年，然后突然觉得，等等，难道你就是我要找的那个人吗？我认为，当我们意识到与某人有深深的契合感时，这种感觉是很难忽视的。我也相信我们可以两者兼得。确实需要激情和火花。你知道，你确实需要真正觉得你对他们着迷并且你爱他们。但如果几周几个月过去后，随着时间的推移，你发现你们无法沟通，你们实际上并不理解对方。它并不像你想象的那么毫不费力。这可能会是一次非常残酷的惊醒。
And you can feel very blindsided by the realization. and what you realize you've missed all along is the compatibility. You've thought that that's what the chemistry was and it's not. And I think in our 20s in particular, or at any age, really, you know, I'm going to take that back at any age. You don't want to waste your precious time in a relationship or even a friendship for that matter where no matter how hard you try, the thing that would make you to click is just not there. You know, take it from me. I have been there, done that, got the souvenirs.
而且你可能会因为这种领悟而感到非常措手不及。而你意识到自己一直错过的是契合度。你一直以为那就是化学反应，其实并不是。我认为特别是在我们20多岁的时候，或者无论在什么年龄，真的，你知道，我要收回这句话，无论在什么年龄。你都不想把宝贵的时间浪费在一段感情甚至是一段友情上：无论你多么努力，那种能让你们一拍即合的东西就是不存在。你知道，听我的。我经历过，做过，连纪念品都拿到了。
and although I wouldn't take those choices back, you know, it was very important for my growth as a person, I do wish that there was some things that I'd learned to recognize earlier, so I didn't have to learn the lesson twice. Luckily, for me, I'm now with an amazing person with whom I have both compatibility and chemistry with, and I've realized there are some essential things that do define a good relationship, specifically a relationship that is secure. So consider this your checklist, whether you are dating someone new, you are unsure about the relationship you're currently in,
虽然我不会收回那些选择，你知道的，这对我的个人成长非常重要，但我确实希望有些事情我能早点学会去识别，这样我就不用把同一堂课学两遍了。幸运的是，我现在和一个非常棒的人在一起，我们之间既有契合度又有化学反应，我也意识到确实有一些基本要素定义了一段美好的感情，特别是一段充满安全感的感情。所以，无论你是在约会新人、对目前的感情感到不确定，
or you just want some sense of your standards. I want to talk through all the psychology, the studies, the research on what makes two people compatible. Without further ado, let's get into it. Some people really don't agree with me when I say that two people who aren't compatible, just simply cannot be together. Like, if it's not there, it's not there. But I really do fully believe that there has to be some fundamental emotional similarity
还是只想了解一下自己的标准，就把这当作你的清单吧。我想梳理一下关于什么让两个人契合的所有心理学、研究和调查。废话不多说，我们切入正题。有些人真的不同意我的观点，当我提出两个不契合的人，就是绝对不能在一起时。就像，如果没有那种感觉，就是没有。但我真的完全相信，在考虑约会之前，两个人之间必须具备某种根本的情感相似性。
between two people before they even consider dating. And it cannot just be a physical impulse or just a sense of attraction. Like, you know if you're attracted to somebody, you can tell pretty quickly if it's mutual, but compatibility to me, although it does take. take more time is so worth it. And it's this instinct that without even knowing that, you know, this person could learn everything about you. This person in some ways already does see you very, very deeply. You know, there is some part of you reflected in them, a way of seeing the world, a way of handling emotions, a respect, a likeness. Like, it's a depth that you share. And I know
而这绝不能仅仅是一种生理冲动或单纯的吸引力。就像，如果你被某人吸引，你是知道的，你很快就能看出这是否是双向的，但对我来说，契合度虽然需要。需要更多的时间，但绝对物超所值。这是一种直觉：无需言语，你知道这个人可以了解关于你的一切。这个人从某种程度上讲，已经非常非常深地看懂了你。你知道，你身上的一部分在他们身上得到了映照，那是一种看世界的方式、一种处理情绪的方式、一种尊重、一种相似。就像，你们共享着一种深度。我知道
that sounds very, very intangible. We're going to talk about exactly what that looks like, but I think when you don't have that, you will never feel fulfilled by the other person. Like, they just simply don't meet your emotional needs. And it's very, very hard to ignore. Now, I will say, and I say this like to my friends quite a lot, actually. It's not uncommon to occasionally have doubts about your relationship. I really want to impress that. Like at some stage, I think everyone will say to themselves, is this person right for me? And I actually think that's a really good sign. It's really important to reevaluate at certain points in your relationship that this is working
这听清楚非常非常抽象。我们接下来会讨论它具体是什么样的，但我认为当你没有这种感觉时，你永远不会从对方那里获得满足感。就像，他们根本无法满足你的情感需求。而且这非常非常难忽视。现在，我要说的是，我其实经常对我的朋友们这么说。对自己的感情偶尔产生怀疑并不是什么罕见的事。我真的很想强调这一点。就像在某个阶段，我想每个人都会对自己说，这个人真的适合我吗？我其实觉得这是一个很好的迹象。在感情的某些特定节点重新评估这一点非常重要：这行得通吗？
that you actually want to be there, that you're not just like passively engaging in the relationship because it's the path of least resistance because, you know, you've just gotten used to them. I really think that you can still have arguments in healthy compatible relationships. you can still feel misunderstood, you still will have to compromise or disagree, and it doesn't mean that they are not right for you. But that cannot be the core experience of being in a relationship with someone. It cannot be constant fights, constant misunderstandings, the same fights which, you know, give such a beautiful sense of relief when they're done that you confuse it with love.
你其实是想留在这里的，你并不是因为这是阻力最小的路径，因为，你知道的，你只是习惯了他们，才被动地维系这段感情。我真的认为，在健康契合的感情中，你们仍然可能会争吵。你们仍然可能会感到被误解，你们仍然需要妥协或意见不合，这并不意味着他们不适合你。但这不能成为与某人交往的核心体验。不能是不断的争吵、不断的误解，那些在结束时带来如此美妙的解脱感、以至于让你把它误认为是爱的争吵。
Like it cannot be feeling cold in the relationship or a sense of relief when you're not together. I watched this really amazing interview on YouTube the other day of this woman. Her name is Spirit. I think she just goes by spirit. And she explains what it feels like to be in an emotionally incompatible friendship or relationship. And the way she describes it is the circle and the square. So what you would imagine like a big square, you can even draw it down, like a big square. and inside is a circle and the circle touches each side of the square.
不能是感觉在感情中很冷漠，或者不在彼此身边时反而感到解脱。前几天我在YouTube上看到一个非常精彩的访谈，采访了一位女性。她的名字叫Spirit。我想她就叫Spirit。她解释了身处一段情感上不契合的友情或感情中是什么感觉。她用圆和方来形容。所以你可以想象一个大正方形，你甚至可以把它画出来，就像一个大正方形。里面有一个圆，这个圆接触着正方形的每一条边。
It feels supported, you know, every side is touched, but there are these gaps where the circle cannot touch the corners of the square because it's obviously not a square. And those gaps between the circles, edges and the corners of the square, those are our unmet needs. The circle and the square can never feel completely supported while they are with each other because there is all this space that is miscommunication, all this space in which doubt flows in. You want to be with someone who it feels like you really, really fit. And I will leave a link to this YouTube video because it's really, really good.
它感觉得到了支撑，你知道，每一边都被接触到了，但存在一些间隙，圆无法触及正方形的四个角，因为它显然不是一个正方形。圆的边缘和正方形的角之间的这些间隙，就是我们未被满足的需求。圆和方在一起时，永远无法感受到完全的支撑，因为中间存在着所有这些沟通不畅的空间、所有这些让怀疑滋生的空间。你想和这样的人在一起：感觉你们真的、真的非常契合。我会把这个YouTube视频的链接留在下方，因为它真的非常非常好。
And I feel like it's a very visual way of seeing it. But I think the first time I watched it, I was like, oh, that totally makes sense. Like all of these relationships from my past, I've just been trying to be the circle to the square. or like the triangle to the square doesn't work. So let's talk about the five signs now. I've rambled on long enough. Let's talk about what they are. I think the first sign that you are compatible with someone
我觉得这是一种非常直观的观察方式。但我想我第一次看的时候，我就想，哦，这太有道理了。就像我过去的这些感情，我一直都只是在试图扮演适合正方形的那个圆。或者像适合正方形的三角形，这是行不通的。那我们现在来聊聊这五个迹象吧。我废话够久了。我们来聊聊它们到底是什么。我认为你与某人契合的第一个迹象
is that you feel emotionally safe and there is this sense of coming home to them. Some part of you can finally rest. And I think this is a big distinction between chemistry and compatibility. The butterflies aren't as overwhelming. They're still there, but above all else, you are feeling like everything is quite still. You know, there's a famous quote that we think butterflies mean we're in love, but they really just mean anxiety.
是你会感到情感上的安全，并且有一种回到他们身边、就像回家的感觉。你的一部分终于可以放松下来了。我认为这是化学反应和契合度之间的一个巨大区别。那种小鹿乱撞的感觉不再那么压倒一切。它们依然存在，但最重要的是，你会觉得一切都相当平静。你知道，有一句名言：我们以为小鹿乱撞意味着我们坠入爱河，但其实它们只意味着焦虑。
And I tend to agree. It's why I always ask myself the question, is this excitement or is this nausea? Because they do tend to feel eerily similar, and sometimes you can't always tell the difference. Or when you meet the right person, you honestly might confuse it with boredom. And I think it's because your body is used to feeling very alert and hypervigilant around people. And now with this person, like, you can finally rest. And I know this is very difficult for people who are naturally anxious to be able to discern. I think if you are someone who is quite socially anxious or just has generalized anxiety,
我对此表示赞同。这就是为什么我总是问自己这样一个问题：这是兴奋还是恶心？因为它们确实往往惊人地相似，有时你无法总是分辨出区别。或者当你遇到对的人时，你老实说可能会把它误认为是无聊。我想这是因为你的身体习惯了在其他人面前保持高度警惕和过度防备。而现在和这个人在一起，就像，你终于可以放松了。我知道这对于天生焦虑的人来说很难分辨。我想如果你是一个社交焦虑比较严重或者只是有广泛性焦虑的人，
like any first date, any time meeting a new person, it can naturally, and it will instinctually spike your anxiety. So you might be going through life being like, oh my gosh, Gemma told me that it should feel peaceful, but I never feel peaceful anyways. So how am I meant to tell? Same with like relationship trauma. You can find dating to just honestly always be a very scary or fearful experience. But I want you to just take note of the times and who you are with when your body feels at ease, whether it is that like even just for a couple of minutes, you exit a stressed state.
任何第一次约会，任何时候遇到新的人，都会自然而然地、本能地让你的焦虑飙升。所以你可能会在生活中这样想：哦天哪，杰玛告诉我应该感到平静，但我无论如何从来都没有感到过平静。那我该怎么分辨呢？对待感情创伤也是一样。你可能会发现约会老实说总是变成一种非常可怕或恐惧的体验。但我希望你能留意那些让你身体感到轻松的时刻以及你和谁在一起，哪怕只是短短几分钟，你摆脱了压力状态。
And, you know, sometimes that can mean that you have to be friends with people first. And that's how you overcome the dating trauma or a sense of anxiety around meeting new people. I think that's a really great way to meet someone who you genuinely are compatible with and that you like. I experienced this with my boyfriend. And we weren't friends to begin with. But at the time I met him our first date. After our first date, I left the date and I was like to my friends, I felt like almost a little bit. bored. Like, I felt bored almost. And they were like, weren't you on a date for like four,
而且，有时这意味着你必须先和别人做朋友。这就是你如何克服约会创伤或对结识新人的焦虑感的方式。我认为这是结识你真正契合且喜欢的人的一种绝佳方式。我和我男友在一起时就经历过这种感觉。我们一开始并不是朋友。但在我遇到他时我们的第一次约会。我们的第一次约会结束后，我离开约会现场，对我的朋友们说，我感觉几乎有点。无聊。就像，我几乎感到无聊。他们说，你不是约会了大概四、
five hours? And you went to like three different locations. Like, you went out for dinner. You went out for a drink. You went out for frozen yogurt. Like, you obviously weren't bored if you were still there. And I was like, oh, yeah, like, you're probably right. And I obviously went on another date with him and it was like wonderful. But it felt like giddy and fun rather than stressful and tense. Like, I was not confused by what that feeling was. Something that also was very, very apparent with him was like, again, this sense of like, have I known you for a long time?
五个小时吗？而且你们去了大约三个不同的地方。比如，你们出去吃晚饭了。你们出去喝一杯了。你们去吃冷冻酸奶了。如果你还在那儿，你显然不会无聊。我说，哦，对啊，可能吧，你大概是对的。然后我显然又和他约会了一次，感觉太棒了。但那种感觉是轻快而有趣的，而不是充满压力和紧绷的。就像，我没有搞混那种感觉到底是什么。有一点和他在一起时也非常非常明显，那就是，再次强调，这种感觉：我是不是认识你很久了？
Like, I feel like I've met you before. We even were trying to do this like backtracking math where I was like, I just feel like this is not the first time we have met. And I know for like a scientific psychology podcast, that sounds very woo-woo, but I don't know. That's just how it really felt. And this really brings me kind of somewhat to my next sign of deep emotional compatibility. And it's probably the most obvious one.
就像，我觉得我以前见过你。我们甚至试图做这种回溯式的数学计算，当时我说，我只是觉得这不是我们第一次见面。对于一个讲科学的心理学播客来说，这听起来可能有点太玄学了，但我不知道。这确实就是我的真实感受。这真的让我多少引出了下一个深层情感契合的迹象。它可能也是最显而易见的一个。
It feels like talking takes no effort. We have all had that experience of talking to someone like at a party or at an event. And it genuinely feels like you are pulling out your eyelashes. Like each sentence, each question is a stretch. It's a struggle. And it's the worst. Like, it's awful. But then, on the flip side, sometimes you meet these people who you, like, immediately, like,
你会觉得说话完全不费力。我们都有过这样的经历：在派对或活动中和某人聊天。真的感觉就像在拔自己的眼睫毛一样。每一句话，每一个问题都是一种拉伸。是一种挣扎。感觉糟透了——太糟糕了。但另一方面，有时你会遇到这样的人：你，就像，立刻，
you are on the same frequency, like platonic or romantic. The banter is perfect. There is a lovely balance between serious and emotional, but also jovial, and light. And the conversation almost feels like you've entered a flow state. Like, you just feel like you don't want to leave the hours of passing by. You kind of forget to look up. you forget about what's around you. Like, you never run out of things to say.
你们在同一个频率上，无论是柏拉图式的还是浪漫的。这种幽默风趣恰到好处。严肃、感性与风趣、轻松之间有一种极好的平衡。这种对话几乎让你进入了一种心流状态。就像，你根本不想离开，时间悄悄流逝。你甚至忘了抬头，
This is, like, I think, one of the most magical parts about being human and about falling in love or, like, finding yourself in a new connection or friendship. Like, it's so magical. Like, it's just like, wow, you get me. I get you. We're both here on this planet and here we are talking and it just feels so natural. And even if you're quite introverted, I do still think that this can happen, even if you're quite shy. I think it just feels like if you share similar values and similar interests,
你忘记了周围的一切。你们永远有说不完的话。这，我觉得，是身为人类以及坠入爱河，或者在新的关系或友情中找到彼此，最神奇的部分之一。这太神奇了。就像，哇，你懂我。我懂你。我们都在这个星球上，而此时此刻我们在这里交谈，感觉是如此自然。即使你相当内向，我也依然认为这会发生，即使你相当害羞。我想这就像：如果你分享相似的价值观和相似的兴趣，
you don't feel judged talking to that person. You don't feel like talking to them it's going to put you at risk. It doesn't feel like your personalities are creating friction. Like they're very, very harmonious. This really brings me to another point and it's a very crucial ingredient for compatibility. I don't think you can have a fulfilling relationship with someone whose communication style and personality constantly clashes with yours. For example, the one-upper, someone who always has to come up with a better story, a better example, that might be great for people who are competitive and want to be challenged, but for the average person, you know, you're probably not going to get along with this person.
你和那个人说话时不会感到被评判。你不会觉得和他们说话会让自己面临风险。感觉你们的个性不会产生摩擦。它们非常非常和谐。这真的把我带到了另一点，这也是契合度的一个至关重要的要素。我不认为你可以和沟通风格和个性与你不断冲突的人建立一段充实的感情。例如，喜欢抢话头的人，总是得想出一个更好的故事、更好的例子来压你一头。这对于那些具有竞争意识、渴望接受挑战的人来说可能很棒，但对于普通人来说，你知道，你可能不会和这种人合得来。
Same with people who are quite self-centered and arrogant in a conversation. It's pretty hard to feel like you're flowing with someone who is talking about their wealth or their accomplishments all the time, or someone who is always looking over your shoulder for someone better to talk to or who gives one word answers. I think how someone presents in a conversation is how they enter a relationship. So if they are present, if they connect with you, if they're focused and generous, I think that's a really, really good sign. So this brings me to my third sign. You acknowledge each other's but still value the same things. The most compatible people I know are not identical.
那些在对话中非常以自我中心、傲慢自大的人也是如此。和一个整天谈论自己的财富或成就的人聊天，或者和一个总是越过你的肩膀寻找更好聊的对象、或者只给出一字回答的人聊天，想产生心流是非常困难的。我认为一个人在对话中呈现出的状态，就是他们进入一段感情的方式。所以如果他们全情投入，如果他们与你连接，如果他们专注而慷慨，我认为这是一个非常非常好的迹象。这就把我带到了我的第三个迹象。你们承认彼此的不同，但依然珍视相同的东西。我认识的最契合的人并不完全一样。
They are actually very different and they insist on being their own people. They like each other, they love each other because each person puts time and energy into themselves. And so the individual things that they have fallen in love with, they don't disappear when they become one, I guess. Also, I think independence shows that both people respect to the other person's personhood. That's just like critical, critical, critical, critical. Let's talk about what we need to have in common, though, despite our individual brilliance.
他们实际上非常不同，并且坚持做他们自己。他们喜欢彼此，他们爱彼此，是因为每个人都为自己投入了时间和和精力。因此，当他们合二为一（我想这么说）时，他们所爱上的那些独特的个人特质并没有消失。此外，我认为独立性表明双方都尊重对方的人格。这简直是关键、关键、关键、关键中的关键。不过，抛开我们各自的光芒不谈，我们来聊聊需要有哪些共同点。
So a question I get all the time is, can I be in a relationship with someone who has opposing political differences to me? I especially got this after the U.S. election when people were like, hey, my boyfriend or husband voted for Trump. or my girlfriend voted independent. Like, can this still work? Let's talk about a 2023 study conducted in Italy that will answer that question for us. Not completely answer. Gives us a good insight. So the authors of this paper, they recruited 274 Italian adults to take part in a short online survey.
所以我经常遇到的一个问题是：我可以和一个政治观点与我截然相反的人谈恋爱吗？特别是美国大选后，我经常听到这种言论，人们会说：嘿，我的男友或丈夫把票投给了特朗普。或者我的女朋友投给无党派候选人了。这还能行得通吗？我们来聊聊2023年在意大利进行的一项研究，它将为我们解答这个问题。虽然不能完全解答，但能给我们带来很好的洞察。这篇论文的作者们招募了274名意大利成年人参加了一项简短的网络调查。
In the survey, they wanted participants to rank which of 153 characteristics from morals to humor to intelligence, were the ones they'd most like to share or have in common with a romantic partner. The most important compatibility characteristic for these people was having and sharing similar viewpoints on important issues like sexism, abortion, human rights, the death penalty and gender roles. But, you know, more general political beliefs in like specific economic policies, like that wasn't really that important.
在调查中，他们要求参与者对153个特征（从道德、幽默感到智力）进行排序，选出他们最想与浪漫伴侣分享或共同拥有的特征。对这些人来说，最重要的契合特征是：在诸如性别歧视、堕胎、人权、死刑和性别角色等重要议题上，拥有并分享相似的观点。但是，你知道，关于具体经济政策等更广泛的政治信仰，其实并不是那么重要。
Like basically, people wanted to share morals. with their partner. And of course, who you vote for does indicate your moral values or your moral perspective. A more recent study from last year, 24, so very timely, examined the impact of political dissimilarity on romantic relationships. The researchers studied more than 500 couples, and they looked at whether people voted the same and how their relationship was impacted if they didn't. And they found that not agreeing on politics created more friction. and less satisfaction. Again, this seemed most powerful when the political differences were about issues that had moral
基本上，人们希望和伴侣分享道德观。当然，你投票给谁确实表明了你的道德价值观或道德视角。去年（2024年）的一项更新的研究，非常具有时效性，考察了政治异质性对恋爱关系的影响。研究人员研究了500多对情侣，他们观察人们的投票是否一致，以及如果不一致会对他们的关系产生什么影响。他们发现，在政治上意见不合会产生更多的摩擦。
implications. And they also found that in general, more and more people do consider political alignment when it comes to their dating choices. So it's not about politics. So this is what I really want to express. It's not about politics. It's about values. Other values that are important to share as found by that original Italian study,
并且满意度会降低。同样，当政治分歧涉及具有道德意义的议题时，这种影响似乎最为强烈。他们还发现，总的来说，越来越多的人在选择约会对象时会考虑政治立场的一致性。所以这其实无关政治。这正是我真正想表达的。这无关政治。这关乎价值观。正如最初的那项意大利研究所发现的，其他需要分享的重要价值观包括：
people want to raise their kids in a similar way if they want kids. kids, they want to have similarities in terms of lifestyle. Religion, about 76% of people said that that was important. And also how they express and perceive emotions, which we are going to discuss next. But I think that all feels very self-explanatory, right? Like the things you would fight with about your family and that you would disagree with about your friend's lifestyle, you don't want that to be reflected in your partner. Like, it's going to make it so difficult because you're around them all the time. Like that just makes for so much more tension, a lot more unhappiness. Now, for those of you who would say, well, you can approach these things with respect and agree to disagree. I also think that's
如果他们想要孩子，他们希望以类似的方式抚养孩子；他们希望在生活方式上有相似之处。宗教信仰，大约76%的人表示这很重要。还有他们如何表达和感知情绪，我们接下来会讨论这一点。但我觉得这一切听起来都非常不言自明，对吧？就像那些你会因为家庭而争吵、会因为朋友的生活方式而意见不合的事情，你绝对不希望这些反映在你的伴侣身上。因为这会使事情变得太困难了，你们整天都在一起。这只会带来更多的紧张和更多的不幸。现在，对于那些会说“嗯，你可以带着尊重来处理这些事情并求同存异”的人。我也认为这
completely true. I do think that that is possible and shows great maturity, but for things as deeply personal as your opinions on human rights and, you know, women's freedom, it's hard to not then have a sense of resentment over that, especially with the person that you love the most. You know, if you are a woman and you're dating a man who doesn't think that you should have access to reproductive rights and you do, like, that's just not going to work. Like, I genuinely just don't think that's going to work. If you're a woman and you're dating a man who doesn't believe you should have access to reproductive rights and you also agree and you also think, you know, you're pro-life or whatever, like that
完全正确。我确实认为这是可能的，并且展现了极大的成熟度。但对于像人权观点和（你知道的）女性自由这样深度私人的事情，很难不对其产生怨恨情绪，尤其是对你最爱的人。你知道，如果你是一个女人，你在和一个认为你不应该享有生育权的男人约会，而你却享有，这根本行不通。我真的不认为这行得通。如果你是一个女人，你在和一个不认为你应该享有生育权的男人约会，而你也同意这一点，你也认为你是反堕胎的或者诸如此类，这也许行得通，因为你不会觉得那种观点是对你的不尊重。非常复杂，非常微妙。希望这说得通。好的，我们将进行一个小短假，从这种紧张感中恢复过来。当我们回来时，我们将探讨深层情感契合的最后两个迹象，以及如何对自己诚实，判断这个人是否真的是对的人。请继续收听。2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。
might work because you don't feel disrespected by that opinion. very complicated, very nuanced. Hopefully that makes sense. Okay, we're going to take a short little break to recover from that intensity. And when we get back, we are going to talk through the final two signs of deep emotional compatibility and how to be honest with yourself around whether this person is really the one. Stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter.
可能会管用，因为你不会觉得那种观点是不尊重你。非常复杂，非常有细微差别。希望这能说得通。好的，我们先休息一会儿，缓一缓刚才那种紧张的气氛。回来后，我们将探讨深度情感契合的最后两个标志，以及如何诚实地面对自己，判断这个人是否真的是真命天子。请继续收听。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。
And on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of... stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped
在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析我们在奇怪的现代世界中培养心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，看透那些主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾以为种子油本身就会引起炎症。我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力导致的。把自己投入一些艰难困苦中，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方搜索“TWO percent”。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA上双击
Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but yeah, yeah, literally. But just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. So
小金在VMA颁奖典礼上的胸部？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。我是山姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每期节目中，我们都会来到这里，剖析发生的事件，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一期节目，马克·拉蒙特·希尔畅谈80年代的可卡因。需要说明的是，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为可卡因。我随时都可以聊聊可卡因，但确实，字面意思就是这样。不过为了让你们都知道我的意思。马克，这是我们讨论可卡因的第二期节目了。所以我开始看出其中有一条贯穿始终的线索。我们现在还把艾滋病摆在了台面上。所以
Thank you for finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversational.
谢谢你把话说完。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的一年了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。在IHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。欢迎收听我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师卡尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我将把我在心理健康领域十多年的经验和对话带给大家。
with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough.
邀请了许多不可思议的嘉宾。我在说特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时我们在追求某事时，会过于沉迷于追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。而我们还在继续追逐。并且我们不知道什么时候才算足够。
Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross. Because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, Absolutely.
因为人们在看记分牌。生活成了关于赢输的游戏。史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯。因为你觉得在这个世界上做一个好人很重要？你做一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为这是两种不同的意图，绝对是的。
And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now.
这也是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你们真正成为一个好人。和我卡尔·盖恩斯一起，在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中，就疗愈、成长、为人父、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用。搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。
In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct?
2023年，前《黄金单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法院听证会暴露了他故事中明显的矛盾之处。这引发了一场长达数年的法律战来证明真相。你曾两次篡改这份特定的测试结果，对吗？
I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing.
我篡改了一次测试。这动用了大批网络侦探才破案。我希望人们能看到他们的税款被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们揭露了一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。
Greg Lesbian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona.
格雷格·莱斯比安和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trap》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县突发新闻：劳拉·欧文斯已被起诉欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州，正义得到伸张之前，这还没结束。
Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man.
在IHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。任何男人都应该遵守两条黄金法则。规则一，千万不要惹乡村女孩。你玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的下场。规则二，也千万不要惹她的朋友。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。我是安娜·辛菲尔德，在这季全新的《The Girlfriends》中，天哪，这是同一个人。
A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves.
一群女性发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过。我感觉自己像被卡车撞了。我想，这怎么可能发生在我身上。警察似乎并不在意。于是她们决定自己动手。我说，噢，见鬼不。我发誓我将成为他的最后一个目标。他会得到他应得的下场。
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. We talked briefly about conversational communication earlier, but let's also turn to emotional communication because, whoa, like they are very, very different. You can be completely in tune with someone when it comes to the fun, the lighthearted stuff and the hobbies and the interests, and then discover like, we do not talk about our emotions or approach them in the same way. So the fourth sign that you are deeply compatible is that you express and process emotions in a way that complements each other. Now, note how I don't say in the same way because I don't think that's really necessary, but you should have some similarities in this essential point.
在Iheartradio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《The Girlfriends: Trust me, babe》。我们刚才简短地讨论了会话沟通，但让我们也转向情感沟通，因为，哇，它们真的非常非常不同。当涉及到有趣、轻松的事情以及爱好和兴趣时，你可以和某人完全合拍，然后却发现，我们不会以相同的方式谈论我们的情绪或处理情绪。因此，你们深度契合的第四个标志是，你们表达和处理情绪的方式能够互补。现在，请注意我为什么不说“以相同的方式”，因为我认为那并不是真的必要，但在这一点至关重要上，你们应该有一些相似之处。
part of your relationship. You should be able to see where the other person is coming from. There are largely four different communication styles that influence emotional communication. And this is really based on some original research from a psychologist called William Moulton. So he began researching this back in the 1920s, so almost 100 years ago. And it's obviously changed a bit from his first conceptualization. but there is still, generally there still seems to be four categories of emotional communicators in society. These are passive, assertive, passive aggressive, and aggressive. Some people also include manipulative here as well, but I think that's just passive aggressive.
你关系的一部分。你应该能够理解对方的立场。很大程度上，有四种不同的沟通风格会影响情感沟通。这实际上是基于心理学家威廉·莫尔顿的一些原创研究。所以他早在20世纪20年代就开始研究这个，差不多快100年了。从他最初的概念化开始，它显然发生了一些变化。但在社会中，人们普遍认为情感沟通者仍然大致存在四种类型。它们是：被动型、自信型、被动攻击型和攻击型。有些人在这里也会把操纵型算进去，但我认为那只是被动攻击型的一种。
So I think it all kind of falls into four categories. Let's quickly talk about each one. I'm going to start with assertive because it's most commonly, considered the best style. The assertive communicator is what we all should aspire to be. They have high self-esteem. They are able to find a really important middle ground between being aggressive and submissive. They clearly communicate their needs without trying to hurt others and they're accountable.
所以我认为它们基本上都属于这四种类型。让我们快速谈谈每一种。我从自信型开始，因为它最普遍被认为是最好的风格。自信型沟通者是我们所有人都应该立志成为的人。他们有很高的自尊。他们能够在自信和顺从之间找到一个非常重要的平衡点。他们能够清晰地传达自己的需求，而不会试图伤害他人，并且他们很有责任感。
Like when they talk about their emotions with you, they aren't dismissive and it comes from a place of building trust. A plus to the assertive communicator. Like, we really are aiming for that. Then we have the passive emotional communicator. These communicators are the people pleases, and generally they prefer to go along with others' suggestions. They may find that they typically don't express their feelings or needs.
就像他们跟你谈论自己的情绪时，他们不是敷衍了事的，而且这源于建立信任的基础。为自信型沟通者点赞。我们真的在朝着那个目标努力。然后我们有被动型情感沟通者。这些沟通者是取悦他人者，通常他们更愿意顺从别人的建议。他们可能会发现自己通常不怎么表达自己的感受或需求。
They ignore their own personal rights and allow others to also ignore what they would like. What that looks like is referring to others' decisions to make sure that there's no tension or conflict, you know, not saying anything in the moment, which can lead to a lot of built-up anger or resentment. But I don't think we can blame them. Like I think sometimes being a passive communicator is really the only option that some people have in the face of violence or in the face of emotional abuse. I heard from a psychiatrist actually who said the majority of his patients or clients who are passive communicators are those who have experienced trauma in child.
他们忽视自己的个人权利，也允许别人忽视他们的愿望。这表现为顺从他人的决定以确保没有紧张或冲突，你知道的，当时什么都不说，这可能会导致大量积聚的愤怒或怨恨。但我认为我们不能怪他们。就像我认为有时候成为一个被动沟通者真的是一些人在面对暴力或情感虐待时唯一的选择。我实际上听一位精神病学家说过，他的被动沟通者患者或客户中，大多数都是在童年时期经历过创伤的人。
bullying, neglect, abuse, or prior trauma or dismissiveness in adult romantic relationships. And so they have adopted this style to make themselves as small and as inoffensive as possible. Next up we have passive aggressive. We have all encountered this, the individual who, you know, appears not to care, but under the surface is really acting out of anger, either through sarcasm or giving you the cold shoulder or being very indirect and then kind of blaming you for misinterpreting their feelings. They're very prickly. And some would say they have limited consideration for others' feelings.
霸凌、忽视、虐待、之前的创伤或成年恋爱关系中的冷漠。因此，他们采取这种风格，让自己尽可能显得渺小且无害。接下来是被动攻击型。我们都遇到过这种人，你知道的，他们表现得不在乎，但在表面之下，实际上是由愤怒驱动的，要么通过讽刺，要么对你冷漠，或者非常间接，然后有点责怪你误解了他们的感受。他们非常敏感。有些人会说他们很少考虑别人的感受。
I actually say that it's a protective mechanism. It's like they're kind of coming out of their shell and they want you to know what they're feeling, but they don't know how to say it properly and say it with their chest. Finally, we have all out aggressive. The person who says what they want and what they need and they don't care. if it makes you angry and they are very forceful. There is no room for compromise with these people. They often lash out directly and they intend to hurt you.
我实际上认为这是一种保护机制。这就像他们有点走出自己的壳，他们想让你知道他们的感受，但他们不知道如何正确地表达出来，如何理直气壮地表达。最后，我们有全面攻击型。这种人说出他们想要什么和需要什么，他们不在乎这是否会让你生气，而且他们非常强势。这些人没有妥协的余地。他们经常直接发飙，他们的目的是伤害你。
Like there is anger and there is dominance. And that's not to be confused with the self-respect of the assertive communicator. I don't think many people benefit from being with an aggressive communicator unless you are also aggressive and you can kind of give it back. like you can show them the love, the tough love that they are showing you. And like, I guess at that point, they've kind of met their match. But if you're a passive communicator with an aggressive communicator, like there is so much that will forever be left unresolved because your way of approaching your emotions is entirely opposite.
就像有愤怒，也有支配。这不能与自信沟通者的自尊相混淆。我不认为有多少人能从与攻击性沟通者在一起中受益，除非你也很攻击性，并且你可以某种程度上回击。就像你可以向他们展示他们对你展示的那种严厉的爱。而且，我想在那一点上，他们算是遇到对手了。但如果你是一个与攻击性沟通者在一起的被动沟通者，就像有很多事情将永远无法解决，因为你们处理情绪的方式完全相反。
You either need to be with another passive communicator so you can kind of see each other's perspective and understand that this is a protective mechanism or an assertive communication. or an assertive communicator who can be like, no, please tell me, I want to know, I want to get through this together. Same with a passive aggressive communicator. They need an assertive communicator to cut through some of the defenses and say, okay, we're going to work this out like adults, like we're going to be big kids about this. And I really want to do a whole episode on how to become a healthy, assertive communicator because you can shift how you interpret and express your emotions.
你要么需要与另一个被动沟通者在一起，这样你们就能看到彼此的视角，并理解这是一种保护机制或自信沟通。或者是一个自信的沟通者，他可以表现得像，不，请告诉我，我想知道，我想一起度过难关。被动攻击型沟通者也是如此。他们需要一个自信的沟通者来穿透一些防线，并说，好吧，我们要像成年人一样解决这个问题，我们要在这件事上表现得像成熟的大孩子。我真的想做一整集关于如何成为一个健康的、自信的沟通者的节目，因为你可以改变你解释和表达情绪的方式。
It's a bit too much for this episode, but beyond communication, I do think you need a similar style of emotional processing. And this is kind of reflected in that emotional communication style, but it also comes down to, are you reactive? Or do you, like, are you reactive or you is someone who contemplates what you're going to do next? Do you need to talk through your emotions or feel them physically? Do you need space from your emotions or do you want to manage them straight away? I think if you feel your emotions in a way that complements each other, this is a really beautiful sign of compatibility.
对于这一集来说这有点太多了，但除了沟通之外，我确实认为你需要类似的情感处理风格。这在某种程度上反映在那种情感沟通风格中，但它也归结为，你是反应型的人吗？还是说，你是那种会仔细考虑下一步要做什么的人？你需要倾诉你的情绪还是在身体上感受它们？你需要与你的情绪保持距离还是想立即管理它们？如果你以彼此互补的方式感受到情绪，这真是兼容性的一个美好标志。
You know, one person may go silent. The other person gives reassurance and you swap. Someone who wants to respond immediately is with someone who is okay with taking time and you learn how to operate with those different styles together. I think you really don't realize how much this makes or breaks a relationship until you start to get more serious with someone, especially, you know, we know that our partners' emotions impact our own, particularly, particularly their unmanaged ones. So you want compatibility, you know, you want balance and attunement when you work through vulnerable things. We're going to talk about the final sign of deep emotional compatibility between two people, and it is so simple. It's laughter. You know, the saying goes
你知道，一个人可能会保持沉默。另一个人给予安慰，然后你们角色互换。一个想要立即回应的人与一个愿意花时间的人在一起，你们学会了一起用这些不同的风格运作。我想你真的没有意识到这一点在多大程度上决定了一段关系的成败，直到你开始和某人变得更认真，特别是，你知道，我们知道伴侣的情绪会影响我们自己的情绪，尤其是那些未加管理的情绪。所以你想要兼容性，你知道，当你经历脆弱的事情时，你想要平衡和同调。我们要谈谈两个人之间深厚情感兼容性的最后一个标志，它是如此简单。这就是笑声。你知道，俗话说得好
couples who laugh together, stay together, and the science and the psychology seemingly confirms it. It's a surprising sign of deep connection, but when you share the same sense of humor, I think it kind of gets you through a lot of things. Looks will fade, you will encounter challenges, you will move, you will change as people, but if you can keep being silly and keep that light, childlike wonder in your relationship, it seems that like your success is somewhat ensured. Really fascinating study on this from 2024. It asked participants in a couple to keep a diary,
一起笑的夫妻会一直在一起，科学和心理学似乎证实了这一点。这是一个令人惊讶的深度连接标志，但当你分享相同的幽默感时，我认为它能帮你度过很多事情。外表会褪色，你会遇到挑战，你会搬家，你会作为人而改变，但如果你能继续保持傻气，在你们的关系中保持那种轻松、孩子般的好奇心，似乎你们的成功在某种程度上是有保障的。2024年有一项非常迷人的研究。它要求情侣中的参与者写日记，
and in it, they wanted them to report on how satisfied they felt with their relationship, how committed, and how much they were laughing each day. They found that the days when each couple reported more humor were the days when they also were a lot happier, and they felt more stable in their relationship. And these results really support findings from. from decades ago. Like this has been known for a long time that when we laugh more in a relationship, that bond feels stronger for both parties.
在日记中，他们希望参与者报告他们对关系的满意度、承诺度以及每天笑的次数。他们发现，每对情侣报告更多幽默感的日子，也是他们感觉更快乐、在关系中感到更稳定的日子。这些结果确实支持了几十年前的发现。就像人们早就知道的那样，当我们在关系中笑得更多时，双方的纽带就会感觉更强。
Laughter is also a natural mood booster. It relieves stress. It gives us a more optimistic view on life, which is why I think so many of us use humor to get through tragedy in hard times. And if it's your partner who's making you laugh, well, that's even better. So those are our five biggest signs of emotional compatibility. let's quickly do a little summary because, you know, this episode is almost half an hour long. The five signs are it feels like you're coming home to them.
笑声也是天然的心情调节剂。它能缓解压力。它给我们带来更乐观的生活观，这就是为什么我认为我们很多人用幽默来度过悲剧和艰难时期。如果让你笑的是你的伴侣，那就更好了。这就是我们情感兼容性的五个最大标志。让我们快速做一个小结，因为，你知道，这一集将近半小时长。这五个标志是：和他们在一起感觉就像回家一样。
There's a sense of emotional safety. The conversation is effortless. You are independent, but you share values. Your emotional processing styles complement each other. And last, but certainly not the least, they make you laugh. Knowing this is one thing, but how can we use it to almost, stress test our relationship. How do we use it as a litmus test when perhaps we are a bit blinded by early feelings of passion and attraction? So I want to give you a little bit of a checklist here.
有一种情感安全感。对话毫不费力。你们是独立的，但分享价值观。你们的情感处理风格互补。最后，当然也是最重要的一点，他们让你笑。了解这一点是一回事，但我们如何用它来几乎对我们的关系进行压力测试。当我们可能被最初的热情和吸引力冲昏头脑时，我们如何用它作为试金石？所以我在这里想给你一个小清单。
These are questions that I would be asking myself if I was dating again. When I see them, do I feel anxious or at ease? Do our interactions either in person or online or over text, leave me feeling uneasy or confused. Do I find myself having to think about things to discuss with them? Am I hyper aware of silences when we're together? Are there conversations that I'm avoiding because I know that we'll disagree? Do I feel like my entire life is now focused on this person or are there still things that I love to do separately? Do they help me with my emotions or make them worse? Would I bring up an issue with them and know that it's something we can work through? And finally, when was the last time they made me full on laugh out loud, roll on the floor laughter?
如果我重新开始约会，这些问题我会问自己。当我看到他们时，我感到焦虑还是自在？我们的互动，无论是在现实中、网上还是通过短信，是否让我感到不安或困惑？我是否发现自己不得不考虑要和他们讨论的事情？当我们在一起时，我对沉默是否高度敏感？有没有一些我正在逃避的对话，因为我知道我们会意见不合？我觉得我的整个生活现在都围绕着这个人，还是我仍然有一些自己喜欢单独去做的事情？他们是在帮助我的情绪还是让情况变得更糟？我会向他们提出一个问题并知道这是我们可以共同解决的事情吗？最后，上一次让他们逗得我开怀大笑、笑到满地打滚是什么时候？
However you answered, you know, this isn't graded based on a yes or no answer. You know, there really isn't any right or wrong answer. Although there's one that's definitely preferable. I just think that these questions reveal some additional things for you to consider, especially when you're in the early days. And you can look past these things if you want. You can decide that it's not a deal breaker to be uncomfortable when you're silent around them. You can decide that it's not a deal breaker that sometimes you feel a bit emotional
无论你如何回答，你知道，这不是根据“是”或“否”的回答来打分的。你知道，真的没有对或错的答案。尽管有一个绝对更可取。我只是认为这些问题为你揭示了一些需要考虑的额外事情，特别是当你处于早期阶段时。如果你愿意，你可以忽略这些事情。你可以决定，在他们身边保持沉默时感到不舒服并不是交易的破裂点。你可以决定，有时感到有点情绪化并不是交易的破裂点，
or that it's not a deal breaker that you can't bring up an issue with them. But I would ask why you think that is the case. And is it just because you are compromising on what you really want and what's going to make the relationship last in the long term for the short-term spark and the short-term assurance that this person really, really likes you. Now, there is not a single relationship out there that has not experienced doubts that has not come across
或者不能向他们提出问题并不是交易的破裂点。但我会问你为什么会这样认为。这是否只是因为你在为了短期的火花和短期对这个人真的很喜欢你的确信，而对你真正想要的东西以及能让关系长期持续的东西做出妥协。现在，没有一段关系是没有经历过怀疑的，是没有遇到过
some very existential question of should we be together. But I think at the core, when I look at the relationships of, you know, my grandparents who have been together for however many years and my parents and friends' parents and people you see as relationship examples in the media, I really, like, would say a lot of what I know comes down to these very important pillars of compatibility. So if you are with someone or you are dating right now and you are not sure, and you're a bit like, ooh, they kind of don't meet all these criteria. Please wait. Please hold out for the other person. I know that especially in our 20s, dating can just feel so exhausting because
诸如我们是否应该在一起这样非常存在主义的问题的。但我认为核心在于，当我看到我祖父母的关系（他们在一起已经很多年了）、我父母、朋友的父母以及你在媒体上看到的作为关系榜样的那些人的关系时，我真的想说，我所知道的很多东西都归结为这些非常重要的兼容性支柱。所以如果你和某人在一起，或者你现在正在约会，并且你不确定，你有点像，哦，他们有点不符合所有这些标准。请等待。请为另一个人坚持下去。我知道，特别是在我们20多岁的时候，约会可能会让人感到精疲力竭，因为
there is this real stupid sense that like you need to have someone by 30 and that you need to be in love. And so I do understand the social pressure. 100% absolutely. But I think it's better to be single for a few more years than to wake up at 32 and be like, oh, wow, this person really wasn't right for me and now I have to start over again. Like you don't know who is waiting for you to make the right choice in this relationship or this situation and leave this relationship so that you can find them. So please go searching for compatibility over chemistry.
有一种真的很愚蠢的观念，觉得你需要在30岁之前拥有某个人，你需要陷入爱河。所以我完全理解社会压力。百分之百绝对理解。但我认为单身几年总比到32岁醒来时发现，哦，天哪，这个人真的不适合我，现在我不得不重新开始要好。就像你不知道谁在等着你在这种关系或这种情况下做出正确的选择并离开这段关系，以便你能找到他们。所以请寻找兼容性而不是化学反应。
I hope that this episode really, really helped you. I hope that you can learn from some of my own experiences, but also some of the research. Let me know if it resonated with you. And if you've made it this far, please leave a little four-leaf clover emoji in the comments and tell me what you thought or whether you think there are other signs of compatibility that I didn't cover and share them with everyone else. Because I think that's also a really important part of this community, is that We expand on these ideas and I appreciate you listening to this episode if you have an episode
我希望这一集真的、真的对你有所帮助。我希望你能从我的一些经历以及一些研究中吸取教训。如果这引起了你的共鸣，请让我知道。如果你看到了这里，请在评论中留下一个四叶草的表情符号，并告诉我你的想法，或者你认为还有哪些我没有涵盖的其他兼容性标志，并与其他人分享。因为我认为这也是这个社区非常重要的一部分，那就是我们拓展这些想法，如果你有节目的话，我很感谢你收听这一集
idea that we haven't covered yet. I'm currently looking for some new topics for this next season of the show so you can DME on Instagram at That Psychology Podcast if you don't already follow us over there. Make sure that you have left a five-star review of this episode and that hopefully you are following along so you know when new episodes come out. And until next time, please stay safe. Stay kind, be gentle to yourself, and we will talk very, very soon. On The Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
我们尚未涵盖的想法。我目前正在寻找本季节目的一些新主题，如果你还没有关注我们在Instagram上的账号，可以在那里私信我 @That Psychology Podcast。确保你给这一集留下了五星好评，并且希望你一直关注，这样你就知道新节目什么时候发布。直到下次，请注意安全。保持善良，对自己温柔一点，我们很快就会再聊。在《The Look Back at it》播客中。从1979年开始，这对我是个重要时刻。84年对我很重要。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是Sam J.，我是Alex English。每一集，我们挑选一个年份，剖析发生的事情，并试图理解我们是如何挺过来的。和我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如Mark Lamont Hill谈80年代。84年真是疯狂的一年。真是疯狂的一年。我认为没有哪一年对黑人更重要了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. not mean that you need to.
在IHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师和主持人Kear Games主持的《Learn the Hardway》。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都不太安全进行的坦诚对话，但你是和一个知道他在做什么的持证专业人士一起进行的。有多少男人穿着铠甲？它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
在AHA电台应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hardway》。2023年，《黄金单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。欧文斯女士，你对这个特定的测试造假了两次，对吧？我对测试造假了一次。这需要一大群互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一个同性恋。
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%.
迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的脑子炸了。我是Stephanie Young。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。2%。
That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resists. in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person.
这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是Michael Easter。在我的播客《2%》中。我剖析了在奇怪的现代世界中展现心理韧性、健康和建立抵抗力的迹象。让自己经历一些苦难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的人。
Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this.
收听《2%》。也就是TWO%，在IHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方。当一群女性发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将是他的最后一个目标。他休想就此脱身。
He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
他会得到他应得的。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。听女朋友的话。相信我，宝贝。在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。这是一个IHeart播客。保证真人。本期节目还没有评论。点击剧本中的任何句子来发表评论。